RYAN MATSUMOTO:
Today we're talking
about cloud adoption,
data analytics
training, and GraphQL.
I'm Ryan, and welcome to "This
Week in Cloud," where we serve
you the lowest latency news.
Google Cloud commissioned
Coalition Greenwich
to survey 102 institutional
capital markets professionals
to understand the dynamics
behind their rapid adoption
of cloud technology and
found that the demand
for easier accessibility
was a huge factor.
Check out the blog for more
insights and our top five
takeaways.
BigQuery is a fully managed
enterprise data warehouse
that helps you
manage and analyze
your data with built-in
features like machine
learning, geospatial analysis,
and intelligent caching
for business intelligence.
To help you make the
most of BigQuery,
we're offering no-cost,
on-demand training
opportunities, including how
to use BigQuery with Looker
and machine learning.
Check out the blog for
more details and links.
Picking the right
API style completely
depends on your use
case, and GraphQL
is a query language
for APIs and a runtime
for fulfilling those queries
with your existing data.
Developers are
increasingly adopting it
for its flexibility
and ease of use.
And we're excited to announce
that Apigee API management
platform natively supports
GraphQL APIs, allowing
developers to
productize and manage
their lifecycle in Apigee.
Check out the blog
for more information.
If you want to read more
about these announcements
or see a full list,
check out the link.
Any thoughts or ideas?
Leave us a comment or tweet us.
We'll see you in the cloud.